vous connaissez le meilleur accueil
morning c'est une mode né aux états unis
au début des années 2010 et l'idée de
cette mode c'est qu'il faut se lever
très tôt à 5 heures du matin par exemple
parce que se lever très tôt permettrait
de faire plus de choses d'être plus
productif de se sentir mieux en somme
d'être plus heureux et bien méfiez vous
parce que des cartes en est mort du
miraculeux manding en 1649 la reine de
suède invite des cartes à stockholm pour
qu'il devienne son précepteur elle a lu
ses livres et maintenant elle veut qu'il
devienne son propre particulier de philo
lui il se dit qu'il va avoir la belle
vie en étant le prof de la reine mais
voilà elle le fait venir tous les matins
de 5h à 6h dans sa bibliothèque et 5
heures c'est le début du cours donc des
cartes doit se lever encore plus tôt
c'est si difficile pour lui qu'il tombe
malade au bout de seulement quelques
mois le médecin envoyé par la reine veut
lui appliquer le remède universel de
l'époque une saignée mais des cartes qui
étaient probablement meilleurs médecins
que ce médecin lui-même des cartes
refuse la ceni puise il meurt à
seulement 53 ans en suède alors qu'il
voulait finir sa vie dans sa patrie
natale la france mais cette main
tragique n'est qu'une des anecdotes
surprenantes de la vie de descartes une
vie exceptionnelle et exceptionnellement
intéressante
[Musique]
en lisant ce livre la vie de monsieur
descartes d'adrien un bail et j'ai eu
l'impression d'être dans un roman comme
j'avais lu les livres de philo de
descartes comme le contenu de ses livres
et théoriques et abstrait et puis comme
je savais que des cartes était un
mathématicien et bien j'imagine et qu'il
n'avait pas eu une vie trépidant je me
disais qu'il avait dû passer la plupart
de son temps à paris à lire à écrire et
à résoudre des problèmes de maths et
bien j'avais faux sur toute la ligne le
génie français du xviie siècle à mener
une vie passionnante et surtout très
enrichissante dans le sens où elle nous
fait comprendre beaucoup de choses sur
la société de l'époque et sur le progrès
du savoir mais aussi sur la société et
sur l'homme en général je vais partager
avec vous dise anecdote étonnante est
révélatrice sur la vie de descartes vous
allez voir que les dernières sont
croustillantes
on imagine souvent que si l'esprit et
développer alors le corps doit être
faible on se dit qu'un philosophe c'est
un rat de bibliothèque un intellectuel
qui a oublié qu'il avait un corps et qui
sont souviens quand il doit porter les
tomes 2 500 pages ou monter les
escaliers alors ce n'est pas toujours
vrai ce crac et platon étaient des
hommes forts par exemple mais pour des
cartes le préjugé et vérifier des cartes
aîné malade quelques jours après sa
naissance le 31 mars 1596 sa mère meurt
à cause d'un truc aux poumons et les
médecins pensent que le nouveau né la
rejoindra sous peu des cartes fera
mentir les médecins puissent qu'il vivra
quand même 54 ans mais il sera faible
physiquement toute sa vie hier à une
faiblesse pulmonaire il aura un corps
fin c'est à dire avec une musculature
très limitée et il viendra aussi toute
sa vie un teint qui ne respire pas la
santé un teint pâle que certaines
personnes qui le fréquentent qualifie
même de olivâtre bref c'est pas le
président kennedy est-ce que des cartes
suit un traitement particulier d'abord
pour survivre et puis pour vivre avec sa
faiblesse congénitale et bien tout
d'abord il a eu la chance dans les
premières années de sa vie d'être pris
en charge par une super nourrice qui lui
a donné beaucoup de soins et beaucoup
d'amour et lui en sera tellement
reconnaissant que dès qu'il commencera à
gagner sa vie il lui fera une pension
viager à cette nourrice c'est à dire qui
lui versera régulièrement une somme
d'argent jusqu'à son décès c'est sympa
quand même à 19 ans il décidera de
prendre lui-même sa santé en charge
parce qu'ils se méfient des charlatans
des apothicaires et des médecins à ses
yeux il y a deux clés pour rester en
bonne santé manger sainement et avoir
une activité physique modérée il n'est
pas bête des cartes alors qu'est ce
qu'elle révèle cette anecdote est bien
on peut estimer que des cartes étaient
un peu prédisposé à l'étude parler comme
les biographes de son époque c'est à
dire que comme sa faiblesse physique et
limiter l'activité de son corps elle
favoriser l'activité de l'esprit
d'ailleurs des cartes est très curieux
dès son plus jeune âge il interroge sans
cesse son père sur les causes et les
effets de tout ce qu'il découvre au
point que son père le surnomme mon
philosophe vous allez voir que la
faiblesse physique de descartes explique
aussi probablement l'anecdote suivante
at il eu des problèmes d'insomnie je
sais que les spécialistes du sommeil
recommande de se servir de son lit et de
sa chambre uniquement pour dormir à
quelques exceptions quand même l'idée
c'est que si notre esprit à ceci la
chambre et le lie au sommeil cela va
favoriser l'endormissement c'est un
conditionnement sur lequel il faut miser
selon les spécialistes du sommeil mais
comme des cartes lui pas une boule
d'énergie il a besoin de repos donc le
recteur de son internat le fameux
collège jésuite de la flèche qui est
située entre angers et le mans le
recteur qui s'est pris d'affection pour
lui l'autorisent à rester longtemps au
lit du coup des cartes prendre
l'habitude de la méditation le matin
dans son lit voici ce qu'écrit adrien by
et on peut dire que c'est aux matinées
de son lit que nous sommes redevables de
ce que son esprit a produit de plus
important dans la philosophie et dans
les mathématiques c'est vrai que des
cartes à quai à cette période une
incroyable capacité de concentration et
de réflexion concrètement il est capable
de rester au même endroit pendant
longtemps à ne rien faire seulement à
réfléchir à un problème précis et la
légende dit que c'est à cette faculté
que l'on doit le chef-d'oeuvre de
descartes son discours de la méthode il
a 23 ans quand il se retrouve en
quartiers d'hiver avec une armée du
saint empire germanique dans le sud de
l'allemagne actuelle il se retrouve tout
seul dans une pièce chauffée ce qu'on
appelle un poil et il se met à méditer
pour élaborer sa fameuse méthode qui
sera fondatrice de l'idéal de la science
moderne en quoi cette anecdote était
intéressante bien le montre que des
cartes faisait preuve d'une discipline
exceptionnelle pour réaliser son
potentiel intellectuel exceptionnel et
cette discipline exceptionnelle plus
qu'à la figure du philosophe occidentale
c'était la figure du sage orientale
qu'elle me fait penser qui reste comme
ça à méditer pendant des heures un moine
bouddhiste par exemple c'est parce
qu'ils étaient capables de rester seule
à réfléchir pendant des heures que
descartes a pu trouver des idées très
profonde d'ailleurs il avait bien
compris ça puisque il s'isolait
volontairement de la société quand ils
voulaient progresser dans ses recherches
scientifiques et philosophiques
alors c'est vrai qu'on comparez des
cartes un sage orientale quand il reste
des heures à méditer seul dans une pièce
mais il rejoint la figure de philosophie
occidentale par bien d'autres aspects en
particulier il a passé beaucoup de temps
dans les livres mais l'anecdote
révélatrice dans sa vie c'est qu'il
renonce aux livres à la sortie de
l'internât mais s'il renonce aux livres
c'est d'abord parce qu'il a énormément
lu au collège comme il est un très bon
élève et comme ses maîtres sont fans de
lui il autorise à lire des livres hors
programme et à l'époque ce n'était pas
un mince privilèges il est donc tous les
bouquins de la bibliothèque du collège
qui m'intéresse et c'est à cette époque
qu'il élabore sa conception personnelle
de la lecture la lecture pour des cartes
c'est une conversation avec les hommes
les plus intelligents du passé mais une
conversation dans laquelle il ne nous
parle que de leurs meilleures idées je
suis assez d'accord avec ça après tout
l'écriture ça consiste fondamentalement
à stocker la parole donc on peut
comparer la lecture à une conversation
différé mais qu'on verse air avec les
plus gros cerveau c'est super quand même
alors pourquoi est-ce que des cartes
affirme renoncer à la lecture à
seulement 17 ans n'est pas pour la même
raison que beaucoup de ses camarades qui
croient à se libérer de leurs maîtres
d'école en évitant les livres la raison
de descartes c'est que les livres l'ont
déçu il n'a pas trouvé ce qu'ils
cherchaient c'est à dire des
connaissances des méthodes
d'intellectuels fiable ce que révèle
cette anecdote c'est l'indépendance
intellectuelle de descartes à seulement
17 ans il a déjà compris que le prestige
d'un auteur ne garantit pas qu'il dise
la vérité seulement l'immense majorité
des hommes cèdent à cette illusion si
c'est platon qui l'a dit c'est que c'est
vrai descartes a compris que non tout ce
qu'il a trouvé dans les livres de la
bibliothèque du collège tout cela n'a
pas satisfait à ces standards de rigueur
intellectuelle il estime donc avoir
suffisamment étudié les livres le monde
de l'abstrait c'est pourquoi il passe à
autre chose il veut maintenant étudier
ce qu'il appelle le livre du monde c'est
à dire développer son expérience de la
vie concrète
des cartes est un aventurier peut-être
oui laventure sa combine par définition
deux ingrédients le hasard et
l'extraordinaire au sens de ce qui sort
de l'ordinaire à l'âge de 20 ans après
avoir étudié les maths en autodidacte
dans une maison calme du faubourg
saint-germain dans l'actuel 7e
arrondissement de paris après deux ans
de maths donc des cartes intègrent
volontairement une armée hollandaise il
le fait pour étudier le livre du monde
entre guillemets comme je vous ai dit il
recueille diverses expériences et le
fréquente des personnes de diverses
conditions c'est le début d'une
existence vagabonde à travers l'europe
hollande allemagne suisse italie et bien
sûr à la france où il revient de temps
en temps il s'engage dans une armée il
rejoint un ami il s'isole pour mener des
expériences ou pour écrire un livre et
puis il ya aussi plus tard dans sa vie
une autre raison dont je vais vous
parler dans l'anecdote suivante des
cartes passera certes 20 ans de sa vie
en hollande mais même là il ne cherche
pas à devenir un citoyen et il change
souvent de maison ils voient le mode de
vie stable de ses amis et il a envie de
les imiter mais non ce n'est pas fait
pour lui il ne veut pas prendre un
emploi son destin c'est la quête de la
vérité en quoi cette anecdote est elle
révélatrice à mes yeux elle révèle
surtout que des cartes est un privilégié
le biographe adrien à baillet qui est un
homme du xviie siècle évoque très peu la
question on est avant marx mais l'on
comprend bien en lisant sont ainsi que
des cartes n'a pas de problème d'argent
il est issu d'une des familles les plus
nobles de la touraine et la fortune de
sa famille lui a toujours permis de
subvenir à ses besoins à peine sorti du
collège son père l'envoie fréquenté le
grand monde à paris quand il s'engage
dans l'armée hollandaise à 20 ans il
pète tout ce dont il a besoin de sa
poche pour rester libres plus tard quand
il aura besoin d'argent il rentrera en
france pour vendre une partie de son
héritage après des carnets par
richissime non plus mais il n'a jamais
travaillé pour vivre s'il a pu enrichir
le patrimoine intellectuel de l'humanité
c'est donc grâce au patrimoine matériel
de sa famille
alors pourquoi des cartes change-t-il
constamment de domicile même quand il
reste dans le même pays après tout ça
serait quand même bien plus simple de se
poser quelque part d' aménager un bureau
une pièce pour les expériences ça serait
plus simple non oui mais voilà les gens
ne le laissent pas tranquille des cartes
attire énormément les personnes qui le
fréquentent pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est qu'il est super
intelligent dès qu'ils fréquentent le
monde à partir de l'âge de 17 ans il
séduit les gens par son intelligence
la deuxième raison pour laquelle il
attire énormément les gens c'est qu'il
est très sympa humble il ne cherche pas
à dominer il ne cherche pas le conflit
bref on aime être en sa compagnie et la
dernière maison c'est que comme il fait
bonne impression à tout le monde toutes
les personnes qui l'ont rencontré
diffuse sa bonne réputation et elle
transmet de ce faisant à d'autres
personnes le désir de le rencontrer ce
pouvoir de séduction a un avantage c'est
que des cartes à un énorme réseau de
scientifiques d'intellectuels de
politique de prêtres des personnes
qu'ils admirent qui veulent l'aider à
travailler et à diffuser ses idées mais
l'inconvénient c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'il s'installe à un nouvel endroit de
nouvelles personnes viennent lui rendre
visite se mettent à la doré elle aussi
au bout d'un certain temps il ne peut
plus avoir un moment à lui donc il
s'enfuit le poids de sa réputation lui
est devenu insupportable depuis les
trois ans qu'il a passés à paris au
tournant de la trentaine sa maison du
faubourg saint-germain est une espèce
d'académie tentent elles attirent du
monde tout le monde le pousse à écrire
un livre et des éditeurs vont même
jusqu'à essayer de le corrompre pour
obtenir la promesse qu'ils pourront
méditer il est si désiré qu'il se retire
aux extrémités de la ville et ne donne
son adresse qu'à une poignée d'amis mais
il est découvert il reçoit à nouveau
trop de visite c'est à partir de cette
période qu'il prend des mesures pour
rester tranquille il fait adresser son
courrier à une adresse intermédiaire
pour garder la sienne secrète il met
systématiquement une fausse adresse sur
les lettres qu'ils envoient qu'est ce
qui est intéressant dans cette anecdote
est bien là révèle pourquoi des cartes
ne vivait pas en france il ne pouvait
plus y vivre tranquilles ils étaient
harcelées donc ils étaient obligés de se
cacher à l'étranger pour avancer dans
les recherches qui l'intéressait le roi
louis xiii essaiera de le faire rentrer
en france pour que le prestige du génie
rejet sur son règne bien sûr mais des
cartes préférera garder sa liberté à
l'étranger
vous connaissez les rose-croix c'est une
fraternité ou une société secrète si
vous voulez dont le nom apparaît souvent
aux côtés de celui de la franc
maçonnerie elle est née au xvème siècle
avec l'objectif si j'ai bien compris et
de transmettre aux savants et aux
gouvernants de l'europe une sagesse
universelle que le fondateur mythique de
la fraternité christiane rosine kruyt
aurait découverte lors d'un périple
autour de la méditerranée à l'époque de
descartes les rose-croix sont une
société secrète qui fait fantasmer les
gens ils sont censés se fondre parmi les
hommes ordinaires c'est pourquoi on les
appelle les invisibles à paris et comme
des cartes à faire un séjour en
allemagne au début de la vingtaine on le
prend pour un rose croix à 26 ans quand
il passe à paris ses amis l'informent
que son nom est associé à la société
secrète c'est d'autant plus gênant pour
lui qu'il les considère comme des
imposteurs après il n'y a pas de fumée
sans feu adrien by est le biographe
admet que des cartes a bien essayé de
rencontrer les rose-croix lors de son
séjour en allemagne parce qu'on lui
avait dit que c'était une confrérie de
savants cette anecdote est révélatrice
de la notoriété de descartes il n'a pas
30 ans il n'a rien fait de notable et
pourtant on parle de lui à paris il est
un personnage qui nourrit les fantasmes
si vous avez fait une terre scientifique
en france c'est l'année avant le bac ou
bien si vous avez fait des maths à
l'université où on prépare alors vous
avez dû avoir à faire un théorème de
fermat pierre de fermat était un
magistrat et surtout un mathématicien de
l'époque de descartes ils font tous les
deux partie des plus grands
mathématiciens français peut-être du top
10 ils étaient tous les deux déjà
renommée de leur vivant mais en 1637
descartes a alors 41 ans cette année là
c'est le clash entre les deux
mathématiciens des cartes vient de
publier la 10 oct ricains et c'est sur
l'optique dans lequel ils énoncent des
lois concernant la diffusion de la
lumière faire mali cet essai sur la
lumière et comme ils pensent que des
cards a commis des erreurs il envoie ses
objections père mersenne l'ami de
descartes qui s'occupe de sa
correspondance c'est le début d'une
bataille intellectuelle plus précisément
scientifiques entre deux génies français
eux de ne s'emballe pas faire ma parle
de sa petite guerre contre des cartes et
celui ci dit que ce n'est qu'un petit
procès de mathématiques e2 ne s'emballe
pas mais leurs fans qui n'ont pas le
même détachement émotionnel leurs fans
eux s'en mêle et s'est progressivement
de transformer un échange scientifique
en une querelle personnelle seulement
ils ne peuvent pas réussir parce que les
deux mathématiciens partagent le même
trait de personnalité il n'aime pas les
conflits et seul compte la vérité à
leurs yeux donc au bout d'un certain
temps pharma propose la réconciliation
et des cartes accepte avec joie quoi
tirer de cette anecdote elle montre déjà
que des cartes est un membre actif de la
communauté française et même européenne
des savants en effet il entretient une
correspondance avec tous les lettrés des
savants de son époque par exemple il
échangera aussi avec le philosophe
anglais thomas sops l'auteur du
léviathan et comme il ne le trouvera pas
super intelligent il mettra fin à leur
correspondance pour le garder au nombre
de ses amis on retrouve encore la
volonté de descartes d'être en bons
termes avec tout le monde la seconde
chose que je trouve intéressante dans
l'anecdote de la polémique entre
guillemets avec fermat c'est que les
deux mathématiciens sont exemplaires
dans leurs échanges intellectuels ce que
je veux dire par là c'est qu'il n'en
font pas une affaire personnelle qui
n'essaie pas d'avoir raison à tout prix
et qu'au contraire il se laisse
volontiers convaincre point par point
s'il estime que c'est la vérité ça
témoigne du fait que les standards de
rigueur intellectuelle des sciences
dures comme les mathématiques physique
notamment les standards de rigueur
intellectuelle des sciences dures
rendent les débats plus sain
et là je vais cheveux blancs apparaît
style chez les hommes en général c'est
au début de la trentaine moi j'en avais
déjà quelques-uns à la fin de la
vingtaine mais ça va parce que depuis
les premiers ça progresse lentement des
cartes lui à ses premiers cheveux blancs
au début de la quarantaine est ce qui
est drôle c'est qu'il se consacre
davantage à la médecine à cette époque
en bonne partie pour résoudre ce
problème il veut retarder la survenue
des cheveux blancs bien sûr il n'y
arrivera pas donc il fera comme tous les
autres hommes il mettra une perruque
cette anecdote montre que des cartes ne
se préoccupe pas exclusivement de
questions abstraites il s'est mis à la
médecine plus particulièrement à
l'anatomie et à l'alchimie lorsqu'il
s'est installé amsterdam au début de la
trentaine il a dépensé ou plutôt investi
devrait-on dire il investit beaucoup
d'argent pour acheter du matériel et
pour se faire assister dans ses
expériences d'ailleurs c'est surtout
pour cette raison qu'il a écrit son
chef-d'oeuvre le discours de la méthode
ils cherchent des mécènes des gens
fortunés est intéressé par le progrès de
la science qui pourront le financer et
lui permettre ainsi d'accélérer le
rythme de ses recherches et il ya une
chose très intéressante dans le rapport
de descartes à la médecine c'est qu'il
n'a pas renoncé aux mathes aussi aux
abstraite une fois qu'il s'est intéressé
à la médecine c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas
abandonné le monde abstrait pour se
consacrer au monde concret non en fait
des cartes pense que le bonheur des
hommes viendra de l'union de la médecine
et des maths à ses yeux il faut donc
relier les deux mondes le monde des
idées c'est à dire le monde des objets
d'intellectuels et le monde des objets
matériels
peut tirer une conclusion plus prosaïque
de l'anecdote des cheveux blancs des
cartes veut continuer de paraître jeune
il a beau être un philosophe un
mathématicien un homme qui passe une
bonne partie de sa vie dans le ciel des
idées et des nombres son apparence il
n'en a pas rien à faire et à raison
c'est probablement qu'il n'a pas rien à
faire des femmes à la fin de la
trentaine et des cartes fait scandale en
reconnaissant l'enfant de l ennemi yann
ce une simple servante qui est devenue
sa compagne et son amie à l'époque c'est
pas une broutille des cartes se sont
humiliés d'avoir mis une femme enceinte
et quand on connaît les attaques qu'il a
subies de la part des autorités
religieuses un enfant hors mariage c'est
pas le genre de chose qui va l'aider à
vrai dire des cartes un peu la
réputation d'un homme à femmes dès la
fin de l'adolescence il aurait eu des
aventures avec des femmes de la touraine
la province de sa famille plus à
l'époque où son père a cherché à le
marié il s'est battu à l'épée avec un
rival pour conquérir une madame de rezé
mais la légende dit qu'il aurait
finalement laissé la voie libre à son
rival en prétextant que la vérité était
plus belle que la jeune femme à la
vérité enfin bon ça n'a pas empêché des
cartes de nouer des relations avec les
femmes qu'il rencontrait dans ses
voyages et comme le prouve le fait qu'il
ait une vie avec sa servante il ne se
contentait pas d'être un drap la vérité
alors peut-être que la réputation de don
juan de descartes est un peu exagéré
mais cela révèle qu'il a un rapport à
l'amour différent de celui de beaucoup
de philosophes pour résumer sa position
des cartes ne condamne pas l'amour il ne
condamne pas la passion ni le désir
selon lui on peut vivre l'expérience
amoureuse sans perdre le contrôle de soi
même beaucoup de philosophes condamne
l'amour au motif qu'elle amoureux
devient esclave de sa passion mais des
cars pense qu'on peut profiter des joies
de l'amour sans devenir fou et la
montrer que c'est possible en donnant
l'exemple
c'est à l'époque où il a choisi de
délaisser livres pour ouvrir le grand
livre du monde que des cartes aurait
lancé sa célèbre formule la rva tous pro
deo c'est du latin ce qui signifie en
français j'avance masques y suivra cette
devise toute sa vie et c'est sa prudence
légendaire qui lui permettra de réussir
à diffuser des idées nouvelles de son
vivant et aussi sans en payer le prix
personnellement un épisode qui illustre
bien c'est la publication des
méditations métaphysiques
le deuxième grand livre de philo de
descartes il sait très bien que son
apologie de la rigueur intellectuelle va
déplaire aux autorités religieuses qu'il
risque la censure est peut-être plus la
condamnation de galilée avait marqué des
cartes c'est bien qu'il prend un risque
avec ses méditations métaphysiques donc
ils avancent masqués par exemple pour
empêcher qu'on l'accuse d'être athée il
modifie le titre de son livre en
ajoutant ou l'ont démontré l'existence
de dieu et l'immortalité de l'âme mais
c'est pas vraiment l'objet de la
démonstration autre précaution
intelligente il fait corriger son texte
par divers hommes d'église ce qui lui
permet à la fois d'identifier de
supprimer les passages les plus risqués
et de s'assurer de nombreux soutiens au
sein même des institutions qui le
critiquent rond ce que révèle cette
anecdote c'est que même si tu écartes
trouve la vérité plus belle que les
femmes il n'a pas vraiment l'intention
d'être un martyr de la vérité et il fait
preuve d'une grande intelligence
stratégique voici plus précisément ce
qu'ils recommandent il ne faut jamais
proposé des opinions nouvelles comme
nouvelle mais en retenant le nom et
l'apparence des anciennes opinion se
contenter d'apporter des raisons
nouvelle si ça peut nous éviter de finir
en prison ou sur le bûcher
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plus que vous avez découvert des choses
intéressantes et même inspirante sur des
cartes si c'est le cas donné un pouce
bleus à la vidéo et puis laisser un
commentaire pour améliorer le
référencement de la vidéo n'est pas
grand chose et ça m'aide vraiment je
suis romain et j'étais avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous vous étiez sur militer
de culture générale rappelez vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
vous intéresser au meilleur de la pensée
j'ai une question à vous poser vous
croyez vraiment que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont il parle bien sûr que
non sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de
grand chose
et oui il y à 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors et bien en fait il n'ya
pas un seul secret il y en a cinq les
étudiants et les personnes les plus
cultivés les profs et les intellectuels
connaissent ces cinq secrets savez vous
avez lu renan comme moi mais il se garde
bien d'en parler les gens qui les
découvrent réussit à développer
rapidement et facilement leur culture
générale parce que leur rapport au
savoir a changé et une fois qu'ils les
appliquent les cinq secrets ils
comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations c'est dans les
débats et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultivez 10 fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit qu'ils ont sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez moi
faites le et vous me remercierez